teammate most likely to go pro in
another sport TJ McConnell field hockey
most likely to attempt a halfcourt shot
buddy heill for sure most likely DJ
practice I'll say Tyrese he's always got
the dox in his hand does he have the
best music taste on the team you know
I'll give it to him he has a little a
little bit of everything all right most
likely to buy a basketball team one day
probably say me my type of business
benches most likely to crack jokes
during a timeout buddy Hill for sure
most likely to be late to the team bus
buddy or one of the Rooks most likely to
have a cameo in a movie I'll probably
say Jared walk most likely to answer
your phone call if you're in a pinch Co
Carla